vous pensez avoir eu tous les jeux vidéo
les plus bizarres du monde c'est fort
alors aujourd'hui les gens qui vont être
contents et d'autres beaucoup moins
fettah à la béquille par le siège jamais
féticheur des pieds je vous ai refait
amis ponot fob vous êtes dans la merde
allez c'était pour moi ok au jour donné
sur la chine
et voilà une vidéo va devoir juste la
merde [ __ ] piqué menace de petter
maison si on ne lave pas vous n'avez pas
pourquoi je je sais pas du coup à ok
donc faut trouver les instruments pour
la mais ce [ __ ] de pied au plat elle
sait qu'il faut dégager sa tâche une
grosse merde mais comme je l'avais
jamais les pieds
oh oui tu es mon gars abuse pas la
mouche oui à ces périodes si grande et
et voilà ça dégage ça dégage aussi nique
la république
allez je te plaît la bouche elle me
force pas les chercher le spray rêve
mère ta gueule tu te tais tu te taga le
pied tiens je te claque longue mois à
aucun des dix minutes pour tuer de
mouches mon gamin dans la vraie vie on
va plus vite
ok c'est qu'une pile un fichier c'est
quand on va choper du minerai de cuivre
ce à quoi aspire retirer ça ok d'accord
c'est bien et c'est bien du cube mais
qu'un s'il te plaît déjà tu parles trop
mettez un pied quand tu es un pied tu te
calmes mais mec méchant pleut ce [ __ ]
de cuivre je vais partager sur un jeu où
tu joues tu peux tout bas contre à pied
avec un voilà c'est mignon ça dégage ça
dégage à j'ai trouvé make you l'eau mais
oui voilà la solution wake c'est ça
qu'on veut
voilà ça c'est fait jusqu'à zemmouchi
comment mettre les bases des mouches et
je sais que vous demandez pourquoi vous
gagnez c'est vous et moi je vous avoue
que je me dis quoi
pour elle je me dis pas pourquoi je joue
à un jeu à arette des [ __ ] je fais
bloqué par un gros doigt de pied mais
que si j'avais su un jour tu fermes tu
faire des orteils il est où le truc pour
péter les mouches ses coiffures aux
couloirs ya qu allah ya de l'eau du
spray ce stress pourquoi c'est pour les
verrues c'est quoi le mot puisque argent
au placard et fait rien du tout le
pierre laville fait quoi
[Musique]
d'acord auquel a écrasé maison au bout
que la puissance de la pédicure sont
avec nous oui on connaît le discours de
pied ça va ça va on a l'habitude
ok ce parti beach beach au gala là je
vais pas te tueras pas perdre de temps
mon gars voilà ma balle
j'arrive beach voilà on perd pas de
temps elle gotham le temps c'est la
santé des pieds
voilà ça pourrait on s'en bat les
couilles ça dégage hockey ici un
instigateur ou un sécateur
[ __ ] je dois pokémon gucht heigl tag
rethel et on coupe tout ça à ces
répéteurs et ramène tes doigts pied amex
et pieuse ou est-ce que vous ont déjà
poussé aussi loin se faisait déjà rêver
une fois ou pas moi je dirai rien sur ce
sujet à [ __ ] pour moi c'est au but les
chiottes nouveau labour ne parlera pas
que ça à foot [ __ ] c'est bon je les
jeux les jeux ça lag c'est l'esma
pourquoi salle annexe par un bon débat
au départ on y va on y va on y va on a
une minute 22 pour finir ça passe mais
tu as you go go go go go
oui non passe passe pas je fais suis là
ok 2 1 le deuxième aurait subi temps et
l'argent mais l'art et voit là non
hello la pioche elle est où la pioche et
37 chevaux maxi on alterne halte en
haletant on attends attends monte pas en
haletant non ta gueule m'énerve contre
un pied c'est bon c'est bon y'a plus
rien non le spray il est où le souverain
il est où maintenant c'est la fin non
mais ça se passe comme ça on a tous un
tiens comme ça c'est pas grave pas beau
il va écraser notre maison on est baisé
oui la bombe et devrait être là mais
pourquoi il est pas là ce plh bavarois
quote moi il est nickel mon père n'est
plus à ça près on peut parler de tout
maintenant
pour l'ayant des prix on va produire ce
pied virer encore plus que mon visage
hier beach
je me croise les doigts après avoir
touché à un pied alors et alors j'adore
ouais je sais pas si tu étais ce n'est
pas laid mais si ça vous a écoeuré ou
suffisamment si vous avez une petite
passion secrète pour les pieds que
s'effectue sur des pieds y'a pas de
soucis entre outil c'est pas grave
chacun cabinet chacun aime ce qu'il aime
voilà appelez-moi kto view et
franchement si ça peut vous faire qu'il
fait c'est gratuit allez alternant ard
après deux albums cette vidéo partait ou
bien moi je à chaussettes qu'est ce qui
se passe on a franchi le cap de la
chaussette jacques bis
[Musique]